[Musique]
la tequila tueuse ganeti un chakram une
odeur sanglante techniquement Milton s'il te plaît, fais
attention, j'efface
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
maintenant que les vies noires comptent a enfin
fait sa marque et que les vies noires comptent
fait pression pour beaucoup  Il y a plus de changement systémique,
alors ces entreprises veulent arriver
et faire le plus petit ajustement
possible pour s'adapter
au nouveau type de politiquement correct
et cela ne suffit pas, elles devraient
faire beaucoup plus pour réparer
le tort du père.  l'ont
fait parce qu'ils vendaient essentiellement
des produits à base de pêche qui nuisaient à la
peau et ils faisaient également du mal
au psychisme des gens qui grandissaient,
en particulier des jeunes femmes qui grandissaient, des filles qui
grandissaient et ainsi de suite parce qu'ils
mettaient beaucoup d'argent dans
normaliser cette idée selon laquelle vous êtes
inférieur à celui que vous occuperiez
dans l'industrie cinématographique lorsque nous sélectionnons
les gens en termes de rôles, il est si clair
que vous savez que si vous devez jouer un
rôle instruit en milieu urbain, ce sera une
personne à la peau claire et si vous jouez un
villageois et pauvre, cela doit être
fait. Je suppose que la première étape est
de reconnaître qu'il y a quelque chose qui
ne va pas et c'est ce qui se passe et
je pense que la vie des Noirs compte a
définitivement donné une sorte d'impulsion
parce que c'est une sorte de plus grand
débat et discours beaucoup plus vastes
[Musique]